en nous reviendrons également sur les
conséquences de cette crise dans le dur
at il un avant y aura-t-il un après
quelles leçons en tirer c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir et pour
décrypter tout ceci est en parler nous
sommes avec patrick mennucci conseiller
municipal de marseille bonsoir on serait
que mennucci merci d'être avec nous à
ses côtés didier maïsto président de sud
radio bonsoir didier maïs aussi d'être
là l'on va voilà c'était face à face un
petit peu particulier aujourd'hui on va
le diviser en deux on va évidemment
décrypter ces mesures fortes en
d'emmanuel macro aujourd'hui et puis on
ira un petit peu voir plus loin quelle
leçon tirer de cette crise du corona
virus je vous propose tout d'abord
d'écouter une partie de cette allocution
sur la fermeture des écoles des crèches
et des collèges annoncé par le président
de la république tout à l'heure dès
lundi et jusqu'à nouvel ordre les
crèches les écoles les collèges les
lycées et des universités seront fermés
pour une raison simple nos enfants et
nos plus jeunes selon les scientifiques
toujours sont celles et ceux qui
propagent semble-t-il le plus rapidement
le virus
même si pour les enfants ils n'ont
parfois pas de symptômes et heureusement
ne semble pas aujourd'hui souffrir le
formes aiguës de la maladie
c'est à la fois pour les protéger et
pour réduire la dissémination du virus à
travers notre territoire
service de garde sera mise en place
région par région nous nous trouverons
les bonne organisation pour que en effet
les personnels qui sont indispensables à
la gestion de la crise sanitaire puisse
faire garder leurs enfants et continuer
d'aller au travail pour vous protéger et
vous soigner
et donc cette organisation sera
travaillée par le gouvernement dans les
prochains jours avec l'ensemble des élus
et tous les responsables sur nos
territoires
voilà messieurs je voulais vous faire
écouter ce sont parce que c'est certain
l'une des mesures qui aura le plus de
conséquences sur les français patrick
mennucci vous êtes satisfait par cette
annonce je crois pas qu'on puisse être
satisfait c'est presque oppose un livre
vous attendiez non je m'attendais pas à
la fermeture des écoles je dois le dire
mais c'est très manifestement le
ministre blanc car nos réseaux je ne m'y
attendais pas parce que ce matin au
ministre la vie chère a dit qu'il ne
fermerait pas les écoles comme au caire
mais sans doute aujourd'hui à la fois
sur cette question mais aussi sur la
question des élections municipales il ya
eu des hésitations en tout cas des
discussions maintenant il est difficile
quand on est un commentateur et de de
contester les mesures du président
réduite dans la mesure où on considère
je suppose que c'est la vérité qu'il a
c'est ce qu'il a dit en tout cas des
informations des courbes qui peuvent
montrer que dans les quinze jours qui
viennent il nous allons avoir le pic
épidémique look si effectivement les
écoles participent de cela
la logique est effectivement de les
fermer mais ce qu'on commet base est
pourquoi la matinée on disait que les
fermes et pas simplement la halle est là
les conséquences pour les français sont
considérables et chacun d'entre nous
peut regarder dans sa famille j'ai eu ma
fille tout à l'heure il ya des humains
qui est éminemment stupéfaite parce que
la cage faire vous voir on va être
obligé de s'adapter à tout ça je crois
qu'il faut dans des circonstances comme
celles là moi j'ai suffisamment
impressionnant et public sur beaucoup de
choses
bon voilà après je suis pas dupe non
plus de la posture de là peut-être de la
possibilité que voit le président la
république dans cette crise de montrer
aux français qu il est le commandant en
chef en quelque sorte que c'était
l'occasion en or didier maïsto il l'a
dit d'ailleurs emmanuel macron faire
nation voilà la posture du chef de
l'état
paternaliste vous l'avez trouvé comment
avant justement d'aller dans le détail
de ces mesures que vous approuvez ou pas
je ne sais pas je vais trouver
fidèle à lui-même dans le en même temps
on a découvert ce soir qu'il allait
réinventer un modèle on a presque vu
communiste puisqu'il semble en remettre
en cause un peu le néo l'aider à le
néolibéralisme même si la silla pas dit
on allait réfléchir à un nouveau modèle
il parle de nation ce qui est quand même
étrange dans sa bouche et en même temps
il parle d'europe
finalement à la fin on se dit mais il
nous parle coûte de koala du fric site
puisque il va remettre en cause les
équilibres européen et c'est alors à un
moment il parle pour l'europe un moment
pour la france
bon finalement c'est un exercice certes
compliqué mais c'est aussi la stratégie
qui a été choisi de faire du en même
temps c'est à dire on ferme sans fermer
on enferme les lieux clos mais on
continue à aller dans les transports en
commun ont profité à limiter les
pourvois la mémé ça tout le monde
si vous voulez voilà on voit jamais au
bout d'une véritable démarche et moi ce
soir j'ai pas confirmé les écoles quand
même enfin c'est bien le moins qu'on
puisse faire est quand même toute la
journée toute la journée hier le font
pas cette journée était athée comme un
peu folle parce qu'on est parti et la
réunion des présidents de parti ce matin
ça pas du tout été évoquée puis au fil
de la journée puisque on connaît un
petit peu l'histoire maintenant est
sortie l'idée de reporter les
municipales ce que tout le monde
finalement aurait un petit peu compris
parce que c'est un facteur de 2 des
changes du virus
il ya des queues ya les dépouilles
membres c'est cette mesure surtout que
la sincérité du scrutin va en être
affecté dans la mesure où les plus
anciens restes à la maison tout le monde
l'aurait compris donc ap l'idée c'était
l'article 16 pas l'article 16-1 décret
pour repousser ne repoussait pas assez
loin et le président du sénat françois
baroin à lidl go ou martine aubry
puisqu'on a su un peu de l'intérieur s'y
sont fermement opposés en disant vous
allez pas maintenant à six a si peu de
jours du premier tour
changer les règles il fallait le faire
avant ça c'est le premier point mais le
deuxième point par rapport à ce comité
scientifique qu'il découvre un peu comme
on découvre l'eau tiède
ça fait quand même plusieurs semaines
que les meilleurs scientifiques et pas
seulement les français comme il l'a dit
alerte sur la courbe exponentielle de du
virus puis là on découvre ce matin on
découvre ce soir l'eau chaude que ce que
tout le monde savait déjà dans l'eau
comme dans la communauté scientifique
ce que les scientifiques s'échine à dire
sur tous les modes avec la retenue qui
est la leur parce qu'ils ne font pas de
politique
et là d'un coup on découvre finalement
ce qu'ont découvert les italiens avec
neuf jours d'avancé vrai que patrick
mennucci on peut se demander quand on
écoute le président de la république est
ce que ces mesures n'arrive pas un petit
peu tard je sais très difficile de se
prononcer là dessus parce que moi je ne
veux pas je ne veux pas asséner des
vérités parce que je n'ai pas l'ensemble
des informations mais il est vrai que la
courbe en tout cas celle qui montre que
le pic épidémique
on peut arriver dans les huit dix jours
entre les deux voilà voilà
et donc celle là on la connaît depuis
longtemps il ya peut-être eu une prise
de conscience du président de la
république de la nécessité il a pensé
pendant un moment
comme d'autres dirigeants européens ou
même donald trump qui il ya quelques
jours nous expliquer que c'était moins
que la grippe
bon il a peut être pensé que ces accords
et donc il ya un moment il a peut-être
aussi saisi que c'était une occasion
pour lui de se révéler comme président
de la république parce que depuis qu'il
est élu ce n'est que chaos manifestation
des accords dans le pays
et là c'est un sujet où et même ceux qui
le critiquent régulièrement en gamme et
une difficulté parce que moi 4 des
gendarmes qu'il faut que nous fassions
nation je suis d'accord moi je suis
d'accord que la france ça se mobilisent
je suis d'accord qu'on se bat alors
l'ennemi là il est difficile à européen
et je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
stratégie chez emmanuel macron comme
toujours d'ailleurs et que là ce soir
il a choisi la stratégie du chef du
commandement il a beaucoup hésité
dans la journée il a reculé sur la
question des élections municipales et
nous verrons d'ailleurs au deuxième tour
si c'était judicieux ou pas de les
maintenir parce que si le pic épidémique
la semaine prochaine et donc parce que
souvent les données de doublement
aujourd'hui on a 500 demain ça sera
mille est-ce que ça sera 2000 après
demain hélas le deuxième tour lui rocroi
plus l'annuler ben je veux dire boire
leurs portes et bordeaux je suis la
justification en fait la transition
merci le matin ces municipales après un
long suspense que nous décrivent et
didier mais il sauve tout au long de la
journée coûte et j'ai interrogé les
scientifiques sur nos élections
municipales dont le premier tour se
tiendra dans quelques jours il considère
que rien ne s'oppose à ce que les
français même les plus vulnérables se
rendre aux urnes
j'ai aussi demandé au premier ministre
il l'a fait encore ce matin de consulter
largement toutes les familles politiques
et elles ont exprimé la même volonté
mais il conviendra de veiller au respect
strict des gestes barrières contre le
virus et des recommandations sanitaires
je fais confiance au maire et au civisme
de chacun d'entre vous oui mais neil mac
row qui fait confiance au civisme alors
tout en appelant effectivement les
personnes âgées de plus de 70 ans les
handicapés les malades chroniques
ceux qui ont des troubles respiratoires
à rester chez eux dont il moi je pense
que fait ça fait longtemps que le
président a public a pas du voir bureaux
de vote
voilà il ya ça va très compliqué parce
que d'abord il ya ce qu'on me dit ce que
j'aime tant dans les partis politiques
c'est qu'il ya des difficultés
aujourd'hui de recrutement des des
assesseurs parce qu'il ya des jeunes qui
n'ont pas envie de passer la journée
déjà que c'est pas très agréable
d'entendre normal mais c'est un acte
républicain et citoyen mais là on est
dans une situation où beaucoup de gens
ont refusé d'y aller donc est ce que je
sais que beaucoup de mairies ont mis on
demandé à leurs employés communaux de se
substituer aux assesseurs
moi je pense que les gens pensent pas
tellement aux votants mais je pense que
les assesseurs qui vont rester toute la
journée dans un bureau de vote
je vois pas comment on ne tient même
rencontre le président on le fait ici
tout ça me paraît très compliqué très
compliqué le dépouillement dépouillement
qui peut parfois être un peu comment
dire animée voilà c'est arrivé c'est pas
parce qu'il ya le coronavirus qui va pas
y avoir de la politique est parfois la
politique un peu violente dans ces
moments là donc moi je n'aurais pas été
j'aurais pas été appartement où on ferme
les écoles où on prend ce type de
mesures ça ne m'aurait pas choqué qu'on
reporte les élections municipales
deux mois et demi ou deux mois ce n'est
pas question de reporter d'une année
mais voilà qu'est ce qu'elle est les
français ont la tête aller voter
j'essaie un sort aussi comme non mais on
a tous envie je pense que face à des
événements comme ça de s'unir et de ne
pas céder à la polémique facile stérile
sage parce que les français comme tous
les peuples sur la terre le comprennent
très bien on est prêt à faire des
sacrifices et d'ailleurs et je reste
lavez vous les mains fait attention que
ça on n'a pas attendu monsieur macron
pour s'occuper de nos anciens s'occuper
bon là il a essayé effectivement de 2,2
d'être dans cette posture là beaucoup de
dommages appuyé au personnel hospitalier
il aurait sans doute préféré qu'on les
écoute un peu plus dangereux
un peu d'argent et des et des moyens le
grand peuple français et cetera c'était
un discours quand même très long un peu
du verbiage dans la deuxième partie du
discours bien sûr qu'on a tous envie de
s'unir derrière une cause mais encore
faut-il qu'on ait confiance en notre
chef et le problème c'est que monsieur
macron et c'est pas offense que de le
dire est un peu quelqu'un de versatile
c'est quelqu'un en qui on n'a pas
confiance et pour être un père de la
nation il faut être soi même
incarnez un peu la figure du chef au
dessus des partis ce que ça fait cher
jacques chirac par exemple sans faire de
politique politicienne
et c'est peut-être une occasion qu'il
espère en tout cas de ce point de ce
point de vue aujourd'hui on a encore vu
désolé de le dire mais les machinistes
derrière l'acteur on a vu un peu le
décor on a vu la ficelle qui pendaient
et ça c'est pas terrible quoi je dois le
dire donc les français ont envie de se
reconnaître
à un moment dans un jeu dit pas un chef
mais dans une figure qui va les
rassembler parce que les événements sont
pris ce que red être graves
mais là on voit quand même un peu la
politique politicienne et la salle des
machines et ça c'est pas très rassurant
vous parlez
d'argent alors là manifestement l'état
va mettre clairement la main à la poche
puisque cette fermeture d'écoles
implique que beaucoup de personnes ne
pourront pas dé travailler que ça va
être pris en charge
il l'a dit il peut protéger les
entreprises emmanuel macron donc ça sera
mis ça sera pris en charge ce chômage
partiel par l'état 1 il veut un système
plus généreux est d'ailleurs que les
allemands c'est pas inquiétant par les
temps qui courent où semble-t-il et
qu'elles sont vides on nous le répète
répète tous les jours je je fais je
crois pas quelle qu'elle soit vide avec
des retraites avec est soumis depuis
pour d'autres choses ne sont pas beaux
la vérité c'est que ce qu'on aurait
atteint dès ce soir
c'est par exemple le moratoire sur les
nouvelles règles de chômage je pense que
ça se sont était quelque chose oui mais
est ce qu'on demande un débat comme lui
je n'ai pas dit oui je n'ai pas obtenu
la note serait toujours au milieu du gué
voilà annoncé par certains sites
aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs il n'a pas dit il a pas dit
il n'a pas dit et aussi que la les
nouvelles règles qui rendent pas mieux
ces jours ci ça va être une
précarisation de plusieurs être
excessive mais de deux ou trois cent
mille personnes immédiatement
donc là par exemple il y avait une geste
à faire sans l'annuler puisque ça a été
notée b y avoir un report de six mois
comme il a fait un report sur les
expulsions domiciliaire et je crois que
c'est une bonne chose mais c'est dans le
même état d'esprit
mais pourquoi le faire sur les
expulsions domiciliaire est pas le faire
sur le chômage et pio moi il me semble
quand même que la vraie question c'est
est-ce d'abandon des services publics de
l'hôpital depuis des années et que même
au moment où on tresse des louanges et à
juste titre d'ailleurs à ceux qui
combattent
les hôpitaux au cours d'un virus on ne
voit pas les les éléments qui ferait que
ces gemmes dirais oui j'ai été reconnu
en paroles très bien merci
mais je suis aussi reconnu dans mon
travail dans le fait que j'ai de
meilleures conditions de travail plus de
jeunes pour voilà et ça ça n'a pas été
fait donc on est toujours dans la
posture mais c'est un peu l'opérateur
public
alors une petite oui oui on se rend
compte chaque fois quand même qu'à
l'occasion d'une crise ça change
les fondamentaux de de monsieur macro et
de sa majorité
parce que là il nous parle de fermeture
des frontières sans véritablement le
dire donc il dit plus de protection il
remet en cause une certaine maison tient
il a dit voilà il faudra que ça soit
décidée à l'échelle européenne s'avère
gagnant à allouagne ce sujet là je
savais bien que ça veut rien dire de
reporter toujours ce à l'échelle
européenne
si vous fermez vos frontières vous
fermez vous frontières aujourd'hui et
vous allez à menton vous pouvez vous ne
pouvez pas entrer en italie vous avez
des carabinieri avec les gants etc
toutes les précautions d'usagé
vous ne pouvez pas aller en italie mais
vous pouvez très bien aller en france
c'est une passoire aujourd'hui donc les
italiens ferme la frontière faux pas il
faut pas céder aux replis nationalistes
cheikh bin oui mais en même temps il dit
fort offert nation voyez c'est chaque
fois qu'on met c'est bien le problème de
monsieur mac on sait que chaque fois il
y re découvre un petit peu comme je
disais l'eau chaude que un pays c'est
aussi des frontières une souveraineté
un système de santé des mesures qui
peuvent être protectionniste par moments
quand la situation le commande
et de rajouter toujours ces suffixes
dégradant nationalisme se stopper l'élan
tiers 68
en même temps que les écoles des mois je
pense que la fermeture des frontières et
le cndd en amont fonction du pays
voisins quelle est sa politique ayant le
corps d'un virus si on a une politique
qu'ils considèrent être la même que la
nôtre et qui a les mêmes les mêmes
moyens
l'intérêt de la fermeture était un mode
très limité puisque les gens luttent bon
si il ya des pays autour de la france et
qui sont laissés aller sur cette
question évidemment qu'ils vont fermer
pour dire mais honnêtement je veux dire
je pense que ce que lille et maisto est
vrai on a vu les images tout à l'heure
c'est choquant mots les carabinieri d'un
côté qui pointent la température des
jeunes et puis au monde et italienne
passée
d'ailleurs on ne voit pas de policiers
français et les gars y'a pas de
policiers le mans le voilà donc pas
nouveau ça d'ailleurs parce que même
avant le court aux navires us moi qui
vais souvent dans la région là bas c'est
comme ça depuis des années oui mais ça
c'est la loi c'est au nom de ces enfants
mais ce que je veux dire division passe
à wil égalisait puis 160 beaucoup plus
strictes quand même on arrive à la
deuxième partie du débat est ce qu'il y
aura un avant et un après ce qu'on peut
tirer les leçons de cette grosse crif
qui malheureusement n'est pas fini bruno
le maire a aujourd'hui a lancé un appel
d'offres déjà briques années didier
maïsto c'est pas bien c'est que c'est
montebourg qui avait lancé l'appel
redresser un bruno le maire notre
ministre français des finances qui
appelle les multinationales à tirer les
conséquences de l'épidémie qui a mis
plusieurs usines à l'arrêt en chiné et
compliquer l'approvisionnement d'autres
pays alors ils appellent ça un game
center un événement qui change la donne
sous-entendu voilà la nécessité
peut-être de re localiser un certain
nombre d'activités à la nouvelle je vous
entends votre réponse il est courtois
voilà il découvre encore elodie et voilà
être peut-être plus indépendants nous
dit le ministre sur un certain nombre de
chaînes de production vous applaudissez
dès demain problème c'est que quatre
mois que
la 80 personnes des bases des
médicaments sont fabriqués en chine
c'est comment comprendre qu'un moment
pour des racismes 90 combos que ça peut
avoir un problème à partir d'une
situation on peut on peut aussi être
l'otage de ces pays pour des raisons
politiques
hier paillage et à sion détient votre
capacité à vous soigner
c'est terrifiant ce qui est assez
paradoxal c'est que ce sont bruno le
maire qui est le chantre de la du
libéralisme qui nous explique
aujourd'hui qu'il faut renationaliser ou
réindustrialiser sur des choses entre
nous qui sont pas très compliqué parce
que pourquoi les médicaments sont partis
en chine mais c'est pour une question de
prix c'est possible c'est pas une
question est ce que le coût du travail
est comparable au coût humain comme peu
avant si on a une rupture de médicaments
des questions je crois que les verts en
tout cas parole approcher j'attends les
actes aux paroles non mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya des secteurs à la fois
stratégique et à la fois très important
pour la vie quotidienne des français
qu'on a complètement délégués pour des
histoires de coûts avec beaucoup de
légèreté d'un conséquences si vous
voulez déjà coco 90% de la pénicilline
qui servent à la fabrication qui sert à
la fabrication des antibiotiques soient
confiées aux chinois c'est une folie
100% des pédales de freins je prends un
deuxième exemple puisque auront donc ça
ça a l'air de rien mais ça bloque
complètement la production des voitures
etc et on se rend compte avec ça c'est
le premier point est le deuxième c'est
la financiarisation de l'économie avec
beaucoup de sociétés qui sont en bourse
qui qui essaie de fabriquer à pas cher
entre guillemets mais on voit que les
coûts induits et indirects sont beaucoup
plus importants au final est que quand
on voit les la privatisation des
aéroports des routes
tout fleurot pour l'instant un meilleur
voilà pour l'instant on vous une marche
du marché sont par l instant pour les
conditions du marché sont pas réunies
bon et finalement on se rend compte que
tout ce qui a été exprimé par le peuple
dans la rue à l'occasion des idées jaune
ou à l'occasion des grévistes qui ont
manié on a dit un tas de deux noms
d'oiseaux beaucoup de méchancetés et
d'adjectifs et d'épithètes dépréciatif
vis-à-vis de ces journées ont finalement
là encore on découvre que toutes ces
personnes qui étaient dans la rue il n'y
était pas simplement pour prendre l'air
mais parce qu'elle revendiquait quelque
chose de vital de vital dans le dans la
vie même du pays et j'espère en tout cas
où je pense qu'il y aura un après parce
que ça a explosé à la face de tout le
monde parce que nous on a un certain
nombre à dire vous connaissez mes
positions sur le sujet c'est pas nouveau
j'ai fait campagne contre maastricht et
c'est donc pour moi je me dis enfin mais
il n'y a pas de triomphalisme je me dis
si au moins on peut réorienter un petit
peu remettre le curseur
on va pas faire ça du jour au lendemain
on prend que il ya une mondialisation
qui a des échanges qu'on peut pas vivre
en totale autarcie etc
mais quand même il ya cette volonté
exprimée très fortement par les français
mais par beaucoup de peuples au sein de
l'union européenne et pas beaucoup de
peuples dans le monde et cette
mondialisation un peu sauvage sans règle
avec une europe qui réglemente pour les
petits la vie quotidienne mais qui au
final des règlements et des règles la
vie des gens mais ça les français n'en
veulent plus et j'espère que les hommes
politiques en tirerons toutes les
conséquences et viendront réorienter le
modèle 1 patrick mennucci sans faire de
la grande philosophie justement même sur
un pont très spirituel de philosophie
qu'est ce que ce ce virus selon vous
changera peut-être tout cas c'est la
prise de conscience jusqu'il ya des
productions qui se stratégique
alors je ne dis pas qu'il faut tout
ramener en france et je peux en région
parisienne peu importe mais ya justement
l'europe et cette relocalisation
au fond c'est pas une question franco
française ça peut être une question
européenne dont la hausse
j pour l'europe où on aimerait que
l'europe s'occupe de choses comme ça dit
aujourd'hui sur la fabrication de la
pénicilline
on est capable d'avoir une réserve
d'avoir des fabrications au moins de 52
personnes dans le pays
mais vous voyez pas ce que c'est parce
que si c'est le rhum qu'il l'est
ça donne un sens à l'europe aujourd'hui
on comprend les jeunes qui est votre
position sur l'euro c'est parce que le
sansa disparu parce qu'il ya un an de ça
si vous voulez c'est rester un voeu
pieux parce que quand on voit que
l'europe n'a pas été capable de faire
une harmonisation fiscale sociale mais à
minima un minimum donc vous avez vous
assisté à du dumping social et fiscal au
sein même une compétition délétère au
sein même de l'europe
on parle de compétition intra
européennes mais si vous voulez si vous
fabriquez si vous vendez vous planter
des tomates par exemple marché mondial
où la chine est d'ailleurs assez
puissante
ça coûte trois fois moins les tomates
les fruits les légumes ou là où la
viande en espagne vous faites comment à
partir de ça et si vous avez une
entreprise que vous l'a localisé en
irlande où dans d'autres pays
vous faites comment vous pouvez pas
avoir une europe qui parle du même mois
donc aujourd'hui effectivement c'est pas
du repli c'est reprend un peu retrouvé
la bonne entité qui permette au peuple
de reprendre en main leur destinée et
gérer
on a longtemps pensé à moi mais beaucoup
de gens qu elle était européenne cette
destinée et aujourd'hui on voit qu'elle
est plutôt nationale puisque qu'on voit
que contiennent ils ont en appel à la
nation refaire nation parce que l'europe
était absente est complètement paralysée
j'ajoute que c'est flatteur d'impôts
parce que si on regarde quels sont les
productions qui sont nécessaires à la
vie de la société et qu'on décide donc
ça peut être une plainte qui décidez
alors qu'il soit européen ou national
mais ça permettra effectivement de
recréer des emplois sur le territoire
national mais tout à l'heure je
présentais que vous parliez de
2 le maire il ya une autre bourreau mais
bon voilà c'est des choses quelques a
dit arnaud depuis longtemps et qui n'ont
jamais été écouté par personne un peu
plus d'ailleurs parfois trop longue pour
moi merci à tous les deux vides et
milestone aussi d'avoir été avec nous